we've known for a while that over
watches bastion was due for some changes
but now we know exactly what's happened
to the robotic character in the latest
PTR patch I'm Matt in this game spot
news update is holding down the left
mouse button until everyone is
eliminated Blizzard has addressed some
PDRs patch notes which reveal that
fashion should now be more effective
however not every change in the buff he
may enter sentry mode more quickly and
carry a larger magazine in that form but
his bullet spread is increased and he
can no longer deal critical hits his
ultimate doesn't provide additional
armor anymore but being in that form or
sentry mode causes him to take thirty
five percent less damage other changes
include mercy now becoming invulnerable
while casting her ultimate and divas
defense matrix now blocking projectiles
regardless of the distance they've
traveled you can try these changes for
yourself if you have overwatch on PC all
you need to do is install the PTR by
selecting it from the region drop-down
menu in the battlenet client it's not
yet confirmed if or when these changes
will make their way to the full game but
we'll keep you updated as it's revealed
so for that and more from the world of
video games stay tuned to gamespot
you